اسمح لي يا نبدا معك بتقيمك الشخصي لموقف
اداره بايدن من قرار اوبك بلس بخفض انتاج
النفط اولا
مثل ما قصرنا الى ذلك من قبل وعده مرات
فان الامر يتعلق بمقاربت اداره بيض لملف
الطاقه وينبغي هنا الاشاره الى الفوارق
بين الطاقه الاحفوريه وما تسمى الطاقه
الخضراء او البديله بسببها هوسبي ملف
الاحتباس الحراري حوله الى ما يشبه
الديانه جزئيا بسبب راى قابله للنقاش وغير
حاسمه وفي الجزء الاخر لاسباب شخصيه
والمؤكد حتى الان ان الطاقه الخضراء غير
فعاله كما انها مكلفه كثيره هذه المقربه
التي يختارها البيت الابيض هي احدى اكبر
اخطاء البيضا وبدل من معالجه المعضله
الذاتيه عن طريق اعاده تعبئه احتياطي
البترول الاستراتيجي ومضات الغاز
الامريير تحت اقدامنا يفكر والرئيس
وزملائه هو فقراتيون المناهضون للتنقيب
وخطوط الانابيب بدلا من ذلك في طرق لالقاء
اللون على اوبك بلس وخاصه على السعوديين
على عدمي انتاج المزيد من الطاقه
وكان البيت الابيض تحت اداره دونالد ترامب
قد اختار المقاربه الصحيحه والرائعه
وقامت تلك الاداره بعمل جبار قضت عليه
اداره بيضا بسرعه تحت شعارات مكافحه
الاحتباس الحراري وهو امر سخيف واليوم
استطلاعات الراي تثبت ان هذا الامر اي
المناخ ليس من الاولويات الناخب الامريكي
بل ياتي في مرتبه متدنيه في اهتماماته
بسبب ما يعانيه من تكاليف الطاقه والغذاء
وانعكاسات ذلك على النقل والتفاصيل حياتنا
ما يجعلها امرا حساسه